today we celebrate peacekeeping  administration's fourth year of wise and  prudent governance our hearts full of  hope as we rebuild America together yeah  right  talk about hope oh this is the real  Philadelphia 2029 for four years we've  been held hostage in our own city making  your city a safer place but some of us  finally woke up forget peacekeeping this  is war on our own soil every day more  people are disappearing  only knows what the nortz are doing to  them out there in the wastelands its  shoot on sight but at least we're still  free but this this is yellow zone that  means heavy kPa security so we hide in  plain sight we blend into the crowd we  operate right under their feet waiting  for the moment to strike they might  we got a few tricks up our sleeves  remember  is nowhere  you are the revolution  you